Hello Freak bitches,
a lot of times it's just giving people
information right then and there and
saying,
you know,
getting people riled up and excited and
giving them the support to do it.
So,
um,
we're going to do about a 40 city tour
of solutions grassroots in New York
state in February and March,
so we'll do like three or four towns a
day.
Um,
and I'll,
I'll be doing that with Zephyr teachout
who was incredibly popular candidate for
governor who won 35 percent of the vote
against Andrew Cuomo and his last
election.
Um,
and the number of musical guests,
I think we're going to be doing that in
February and March.
We'd love to do the solutions grassroots
tour in California.
Um,
love to do it in other states.
So you can go to solutions
grassroots.com.
You can sign up there.
You go there.
There are links that directly you can
buy solar.
Uh,
you can buy wind power,
you can do all of that at a consumer
level.
But more importantly,
what we're trying to do with solutions
grassroots is get grassroots energy
movement towards getting ourselves off
fossil fuels.
Because you know this,
even though like you can map this out at
Stanford and you have these great,
amazing celebrities all talking about
renewable energy,
the people have to get it done.
We have to get it done.
We have to say,
you know what,
I don't want to buy oil and gas and coal
to heat my home to power my home
anymore.
I don't want to do that anymore.
I want to get off of it.
You know?
Um,
some of the resources are very
expensive,
like buying an electric car that's out
of the range for a lot of people.
But getting solar on your roof actually
is economic.
It makes sense.
Getting a buying locally sourced wind
power is possible in a lot of states.
It's not in California,
I don't think,
but it is in New York.
Stated there's a company called ethical
electric that we have a link to at our
website solutions.
Grassroots.com.
Or you can just basically say,
you know what,
I'm going to buy wind power instead of
buying electricity from coal or oil or
gas.
And um,
you know,
you've done a huge amount right there.
But the biggest thing that we've done in
terms of all this stuff,
New York,
by stopping fracking kept the equivalent
of $57 million cars off the road just by
keeping that stuff in the ground there.
And I think the equivalent of taking 72
coal fire power plants offline for a
year,
the movement is actually going to help
solve these things.
Um,
so it's like,
how do you get people together?
Well,
we just get together.
We have a film screening.
There are a lot of great films on this
stuff.
We have a tour,
we have a talk and you start organizing
locally.
I it happen.
I just bought a new book that I highly
recommend about dolphins called wet
goddess,
but it's available on Amazon.
It's about a relationship because the
only person in 50 shades of grey for
dolphins really?
Did you actually read it now?
I haven't read it yet.
I just got delivered today.
But it's here.
It's like God,
it's so funny.
But it's A.
Yeah,
I bought two of them.
You can never have
too many,
but I like the cover.
It's just like,
it's kind of like a scrapbook with
adults.
Why did you buy two?
Why did you bite too?
I just feel like it's not going to be A.
I don't know.
It's not going to be around for.
You're holding onto it.
You're going to be a hoarder for dolphin
porn.
What?
Look at this.
I mean like they used are going for $61.
Yeah.
See,
I think there's a big mark.
Oh look,
this one,
how has that is probably not the paper
bag.
That's got to be the hard copy.
That's to actually get the dolphin to
fuck you code the code underground about
look at the spout on that Dolphin.
You just buy the book and inside the
book it's just directions to this place
in San Diego.
That's one of the weird things about
people when it comes to stuff like like
a dolphin
porn or something like that.
You would think,
well who the fuck would be into that?
And then you put it online and it
attracts a whole community.
Next thing you know,
there's a message board all filled with
people that are talking about their
dolphin porn and the dolphin love and
their kinship.
Have you heard about that?
Some people,
they don't want to be judged by being
akin to certain animals.
They feel like they're fox can,
like,
they feel connected to a Fox.
I,
I don't,
I can't,
uh,
I can sort of understand to a certain
degree.
I did this movie a few years ago and I
had to write an elephant in it and when
I was standing there with the elephant,
the way the elephant was looking at me
and I was looking at her,
I really felt like I was like,
I really love you.
It,
I genuinely felt like I think I have a
crush on this elephant.
Not in a sexual way.
More like,
I just want to hug you and love you.
Yeah.
Trainers have to fall in love with their
animals a lot,
so I don't understand when they beat
them,
I'm like stuck fucking hitting him with
that spiked fucking stick.
Yeah.
There are people that believe that they
are akin like,
like they're somehow or another,
they should have been this animal
instead of a person.
You know,
some people think that they were born
male,
but they really should have been a
woman.
Some people think that they were born a
person,
but they should have been an elephant of
the shit that's,
that's a,
that's a little mental.
Is it though for you to judge people?
Don't people don't understand there's a,
there's a whole tumbler blog about it.
Good Lord.
Do they
try to manifest physically into these
things?
Uh,
well,
some of those folks that are fluffy's
are furries.
Gabriel,
he's.
And he's flapping.
Yeah.
Some of those people.
I'm sure that's what they're doing.
They're wishing that they actually were
some weird animal.
Yeah,
I think that's escapism.
What do you think?
I think a lot of what people do as
escapism,
including being into shit that everybody
just accepts,
like being in a dungeons and dragons,
that's escapism.
Being into cars play.
That's escapism.
Like at what point do we decide it's
fucked up?
Like it's okay if you want to up and
reenact the civil war.
Why is it fucked up?
If you want to pretend you're fox,
like you're not a soldier from 1800,
you douchebag.
Okay?
You're an asshole who wishes the south
one and you're putting on some ancient
stuff and using a musket,
right?
That's what you're doing.
Well,
why isn't it?
Why is that okay for you to pretend you
were born Arrow with no internet for you
to pretend that you were born in the
time where there's no cars.
That's okay,
but it's not okay to pretend you're a
fox.
Hey Sam saying it's not okay to be a fox
to live and let live love live and let
die it yourself.
Oh,
did you see on the
data dot?
No.